as if westworld couldn't get more
confusing along comes episode 3 and i'm
like i'm completely lost
i've hit rock bottom with the return of
bernard and our first real taste of the
new 1920s theme park there are lots of
new theories and details to cover i got
a lot of comments asking me to avoid
teaser trailer spoilers so i'm gonna
save all those for the end of the video
for those of you interested and i'll
give you a warning when we get there
without further ado i'm not gonna waste
any of your time let's get right into it
the first line of the episode comes from
bernard's son charlie or should i say
arnold's son since bernard is based on
co-creator of the hosts arnold webber in
fact in episode 3 of season 3 we find
that this bernard is some sort of hybrid
that charlotte hale who's actually being
controlled by a copy of dolores smuggled
out of westworld he's in arnold's home
chasing after his son his son used to
play with a maze puzzle which is likely
why we see its reflection in his eye he
opens the front door leading him to
green hills a large tree and white horse
this large tree is similar to the one
dolores used to paint beside in
westworld and a white horse we saw a
kichita ride in season 2. perhaps not
coincidentally this horse will lead
bernard to him the tree goes up in
flames and maybe this is a metaphor for
what's to come bernard finds himself
traveling through the massacred streets
of sweetwater dolores did the same in
season 2. she also visited the mariposa
and took a swig from a bottle of whiskey
similar to the one bernard investigates
you may have also noticed a wolf in the
streets the wolf has been seen
throughout seasons one and two dolores
saw it in the original sweetwater
massacre and william saw it in escalante
in native american culture the wolf is
said to encapsulate strength leadership
and self-awareness through the riots we
saw at the end of season 3 bernard makes
his way to the tower that building
christina saw drawings of at the hope
center for mental health it's also the
building the homeless man said he could
hear noise coming from more on that in a
bit akichita is here and explains to
merdar that he is in the sublime a
virtual world created by robert ford
where hosts can live freely away from
humans bernard was given the key to the
sublime by dolores and used this device
at the end of season 3 to access it
akichita explains that the other hosts
who entered the sublime as we saw in
season 2 have gone on to make their own
worlds yet bernard seems to be stuck he
wants to get back to the real world and
save humanity luckily for him time in
the sublime operates differently than
the outside what's a mere moment in the
real world is a millennia for him so he
can use this to his advantage by running
countless simulations to ultimately find
one where humanity is saved in every
scenario however he dies we get these
quick flashes of images from the future
some of these we'll see in this episode
like the gas station with ev chargers
and the abandoned motel room however
there are shots we've yet to see like
some sort of control room in what i
believe is the hoover dam a tunnel which
i also think is the dam a deserted 1920s
theme park and a small desert insect all
this seems to point at a world where
some sort of apocalypse has happened
bernard will watch as a city burns and
later they'll pass a sign reading
contaminated land with radioactive
symbols on it bernard awakens after
spending an unknown amount of time in
the sublime and judging by the amount of
dust it's been many many years stubbs
who we last saw recovering from his
wounds in the bathtub has been watching
over him bernard will explain to stubbs
that he has to trigger a certain chain
of events in order to save humanity so
every time bernard accurately predicts
something that's going to happen like
knowing the diner would be out of
pastrami melts or that these two dudes
were secretly hosts it means he's on the
right track maeve and caleb venture
through the streets of this 1920s
version of westworld this is the town of
temperance based off of sweetwater and
there are a ton of similarities like the
guy who bumps into caleb and the guy who
bumps into teddy or how about the fbi
looking for the bootlegger hector armon
a nod to the wanted bandit hector in
westworld there are two boys playing
with a drunk the couple getting their
photograph taken and the blacksmith
versus mechanic imagery there are also
hosts who seem to be based off dolores
and teddy we even see this world's
dolores dropper can as maeve will
explain they've made a few changes
the story is the same this world's
version of the mariposa saloon is the
butterfly club a cheeky name considering
it has the word fly in it flies were
digitally added to the drunk man outside
and later this person at the club it
leads me to believe that the park is a
front to convert guests into hosts that
way when the rich and powerful people
that attend these parks go back to the
real world they can be controlled by
charlotte we see this woman talking
about a hidden narrative that's supposed
to be better than pariah pariah was the
border town in westworld where guests
could engage in orgies and almost any
unlawful act will later come to find
that this hidden narrative she speaks of
is a game within a game where guests can
relive the westworld massacre at the
rhodes and diner a fitting name for this
post-apocalyptic world bernard draws the
maze on a coaster perhaps it's a
metaphor for him having to make all the
necessary turns to reach the end i also
love the little detail of him having a
napkin ready because he knew there would
be a coffee spill i found this scene
with frankie trying to call her dad
through the radio a bit weird if i'm not
mistaken her fondness for the radio
hasn't been previously established but
what's even weirder is that we saw maeve
have a radio in episode 1 almost as if
she were using it to communicate last
episode caleb called his friend carver
to take frankie and his wife to safety
but frankie realizes this guy has been
swapped with a host host carver will be
shot by caleb's wife and she escapes
with frankie making it even weirder that
a copy of frankie will later be found
behind the scenes at the 1920s park
bernard and stubbs are picked up by this
character portrayed by aurora perrino
and if i'm not mistaken she never
mentions her name nor can i find it
online that always makes me think she
might be related to someone but who
knows after showing her his drawing of
the maze she asks him how long he's been
with the cause so it looks like this
world has a human-led rebellion against
a world of hosts but with everything
westworld you can never be too sure the
two men bernard killed were hosts trying
to infiltrate this organization who we
learn have been hiding out in a
condemned plant could this be the hoover
dam where all that encrypted data
william wanted was my guess is that
bernard is the only one who has the key
to access that data as he'll later say
there's a weapon buried in these sands
and he knows where it is back at the
butterfly club this world's version of
maeve has the same script about doing
whatever the heck you want a cover of
painted black plays on the old timey
piano which was the same song that
played when the original hector robbed
the mariposa however this version shifts
to metallica's enter sandman hector is
accompanied by this world's version of
armistice that woman with the face
tattoo the robbery doesn't go smoothly
for hector and armistice with caleb and
maeve making quick work of them all an
elaborate ploy to play dead and be taken
by park staff into the underground
they're taken to sector 33 intake
holding and what can only be surmised is
this park's version of the mesa they
soon realize that this floor is simply a
game within a game where guests can
relive the original westworld massacre
dolores takes on the park guards
alongside teddy and angela and there are
some really interesting stuff here caleb
is shot but is unaffected which suggests
he's not a host of course this is not
true for maeve he'll later have to patch
her up saying you
saved my life before having to
return the favor this is a reference to
whatever happened years ago at the
lighthouse and maybe it's just me but
maeve's face here when he says that gave
me maybe he actually did die vibes
something i also found very odd here was
the timing caleb and maeve go from the
saloon where we see the woman talk about
this hidden level and a few hours later
dolores and teddy are taking over the
mesa we just saw dolores and teddy on
the streets of temperance in the
original west world it took dolores days
from the events at the end of season one
to her takeover of the mesa caleb and
maeve escaped to a new level where a
bunch of drone hosts carry around
maggots which will eventually turn into
flies some of these hosts overlook
containers of black goo which will later
be used to infect the flies these flies
aren't interested in may but are very
attracted to caleb likely because he's
human and they're programmed to go after
that maeve is also the only one to hear
this weird noise resonating from this
room while these other hosts can hear it
too but unlike maeve they are oblivious
to its hold over them so even though
christina can't hear the noise in new
york it doesn't necessarily mean she's
human she could also be like one of
these hosts but not know it controls her
maeve doesn't believe these people to be
hosts perhaps charlotte is creating
something new the computer screen calls
this project chrysalis a transition
phase a caterpillar goes through before
becoming a butterfly speakers behind
these hosts transmit the sound in what's
known as an obedience trial having these
hosts perform a series of tasks
culminating in shooting themselves but
things get really weird when caleb sees
his daughter maeve tries to open the
door so caleb can get to his daughter
but it initially does not work this is
the second time maeve has tried to use
her powers and for it not to work the
first was when she tried to turn off the
host senator in episode 2. so
something's going on here too caleb is
able to save his daughter in the nick of
time just as maeve hears the noise from
that machine and somehow knows caleb is
in danger but before she can help him
she's stopped by the man in black who is
in a completely different getup than
when he opened the park a few short
hours ago maeve will kill this version
only to be attacked moments later by the
same one you can see the blood marks
here she doesn't know that william is
now a host but definitely does now caleb
learns from host frankie that he can't
leave someone wants him to stay we'll
later learn this is charlotte hale that
he has something she wants i'm not quite
sure what he could have that she could
want but my guess is that it has
something to do with his past with
dolores and his mission to the
lighthouse years ago the episode ends
with frankie opening her machine face
which is very reminiscent to the early
models of hosts a bunch of flies come
out and go into calo's body suggesting
that he will return as some sort of host
now here is your warning for teaser and
trailer spoilers where we try to figure
out where the next few episodes may be
headed it looks like maeve makes it to
the apocalypse where bernard is stubbs
makes it to what could be new york where
christina and william are we now know
this is lipstick which teddy will pick
up and give to christina bernard and
aurora travel through the abandoned
depths of what might be the 1920s park
since the last we saw him he was around
california and not southeast asia where
westworld and the other parks are the
bottom of the tower here looks a lot
like the machine used to make those
sounds in the 1920s park perhaps this is
a much larger version of it used to
control the citizens of new york or
beyond looks like bernard dies remember
he said there is no version where he
survives caleb seems to have survived
that fly attack we'll later see him back
in the 1920s park and face to face with
charlotte hale in what appears to be
christina's reflection in her eye is the
abernathy farmstead in the trailer
charlotte hale says it's time to evolve
to the species we were meant to become
so maybe these hosts here are a part of
that new evolution caleb has made his
way to new york he's the only one not
frozen here there's a shot of what
appears to be maeve taking an injured
caleb from the lighthouse so it looks
like we'll be getting more insight into
what actually happened here the man in
black comes across a tear reminiscent to
the ones which brought the hosts into
the sublime in season 2. it looks like
caleb is trying to escape captivity here
frankie in new york and maeve
confronting charlotte christina also
seems to be figuring out more about
what's going on with her so not a lot of
answers here but a little insight to
where we're headed i hope you enjoyed
the video please make sure to like and
subscribe and leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below until
next time remember you've been given the
gift of prophecy and
use it to fight stains
you